we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P this is I
was hoping that nobody would notice this
but I am increasingly getting more and
more questions about a video in which I
appear getting a massage take a listen
to this is for real take a listen to
this hey David I saw a very disturbing
picture of what appears to be you laying
on a massage table with the masseuse
sticking her hand under the towel I saw
it on the YouTube channel of the
progressive voice right I was curious if
you could let us know that is thank you
big fan of the show yes of course
yeah listen this so once again people
have been trolling the YouTube archives
I used to when I was like 21 22 maybe I
had a video production business we
produced a lot of instructional videos
ranging from everything from jewelry
making to dog training to massage
therapy and on a very interesting day
back in who knows what year we did a
massage therapy video series for I
believe it was for a howl or
expertvillage and a masseuse customer am
a massage customer was necessary and I
played that customer so I'm not going to
link to this if people are really
curious they can look around and find it
but I can assure you it was all on the
up-and-up
okay we've got a great bonus show today
we'll talk about Eric's whoa well ending
his presidential campaign obviously that
makes sense and many people should do
the same thing there's this really weird
series of people who are licking ice
cream they're opening up ice cream in in
grocery stores and licking it and
closing it and putting it away and one
of them has been arrested and we'll also
talk about the economic impact of a $15
minimum wage nationally based on a new
Congressional Congressional Budget
Office report really interesting data
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership to become a member
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
become a patron both will give you
instant access to the bonus show